Welcome. We're with the master and the disciple, a Persian scholar sits unseen in a strange city, hears townspeople debating without a guide, and picks them as deserving of life because they were already inquiring.
I have no words of my own, for I am following the words of another. So you might be wondering why we're starting today's deep dive with a scene of a mysterious elder just eavesdropping on a town square.
Yeah, it is a striking image. And today we are unpacking this really extraordinary ancient narrative that answers a profound question. Basically, how is spiritual truth actually preserved, transmitted, and found in a totally chaotic world?
It is a demanding text for
Sure, and we are going to explore the rigorous conditions of finding a true guide.
The context of this narrative is absolutely critical for understanding the weight of everything that follows. The master, this Persian elder, carries an immense burden. He possesses profound transmissive knowledge, but knowledge without a worthy vessel is a really heavy kind of isolation.
Yeah, you carry it alone.
Exactly. He has crossed continents, searching through both Arab and non-Arab lands, looking for a true student, a genuine disciple.
Yet he finds no one capable of carrying the trust. Eventually he arrives at the far edge of Al Jazeera.
And he enters a city where he is completely unknown.
Yes, but instead of announcing his presence or setting up a platform to gather a crowd, he simply observes. He finds a group of people discussing religion, entirely driven by their own passions and without any guided authority.
and he just sits near them unseen in total silence.
That deliberate silence is fascinating, especially for you, the listener, to consider. We often expect an authority figure, like a teacher, to immediately intervene and correct the record. Why does he wait?
Because placing profound spiritual reality into an unprepared heart is not just a waste of an educational effort. It causes active lasting harm. When profound authority is handed to someone who lacks the ethical foundation and the internal capacity to hold it,
the knowledge itself becomes distorted. The recipient weaponizes it. They use the teaching to elevate their own status or to manipulate others. So the scholar's silence is an act of supreme caution.
He has to listen first.
Right. He must determine if the specific questions these people are asking reveal A genuine capacity for truth.
or if they are just exchanging empty rhetoric.
Well, I don't buy that yet. Choosing deserving listeners by eavesdropping sounds like the teacher picking flatterers.
I mean, that is a very natural objection, but we really have to carefully dispel that misconception. The teacher is absolutely not listening for people who happen to agree with his own views, nor is he looking for those who merely display a superficial intellectual curiosity.
Because mere curiosity is cheap.
Exactly. It costs the ego nothing.
He is sitting in silence to apply a rigorous three-condition test of deservedness. To be chosen as a vessel for this knowledge, 3 strict criteria must be actively present in the listener. First, the hujah must have reached them.
Meaning, they are not completely isolated from the foundational message.
The true divine argument has already established some baseline presence in their lives.
Yes, they are operating within its framework. Second, they belong to the millah.
So they are bound by the obligations of the community.
Correct. They are not entirely detached individuals. And the third condition is the most critical, they are actively inquiring. They are searching, debating, and recognizing their own lack of a guide.
And that specific condition aligns perfectly with the teaching of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his
It does. He stated that whoever the Almighty wishes good for, he grants him understanding of their religion. The human inquiry that the Persian elder overhears is not just a debate. It is the visible trace of an invisible divine grant.
Human beings naturally gravitate towards satisfying their basic passions.
So when you see someone rigorously seeking truth, which is hard, demanding work, that disruption of base nature is the indicator of a higher prompting.
If there is no trace of that rigorous inquiry, no teacher arrives. But where the trace is real, a stranger sits down across the room and waits to be discovered.
So the townspeople eventually notice this silent stranger sitting near them. They turn their attention to him and ask who he is and what his business is.
He introduces himself simply as a servant of the creator, looking to spread the knowledge he has acquired. Immediately, the townspeople pivot from their debate and decide to test him.
They demand that he define commendable speech versus reprehensible speech.
It's an operational test of discernment. They want to see if he actually knows the difference between divine truth and human ego.
And his answer sets the foundation for the entire philosophical architecture that follows.
Commendable speech, he tells them, originates purely from the divine and calls people toward it. is perfectly aimed at its mark, totally devoid of personal ambition.
While reprehensible speech originates strictly in the passions of the soul.
Yes, and it is used to call people to something other than guidance. After laying out this absolute definition, he explicitly denies having any words of his own.
That sounds like wordplay. How is this different from any preacher claiming he only repeats God's words?
Because he is not making a slogan out of it.
He is establishing the absolute criterion of transmissive authority and submitting himself to it in real time, right in front of them. His denial of ownership over his own words is not a performance of false modesty.
It's the proof that he passes the operational test he just named.
Exactly. To truly understand this, we must look at the profound aphorism from the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
He taught that the tongue of the wise is behind his heart, and the heart of the fool is dragged behind his tongue.
Let us unpack the mechanics of that analogy for the listener. The fool speaks from immediate, unexamined passion.
The physical tongue moves first, committing the person to a position, and the heart is forced to scramble to justify or rationalize whatever was just blurted out.
So the fool is a prisoner to the momentum of his own unguided speech.
Yes, but for the wise man, the physiology of speech is entirely reversed.
The heart acts as a strict, unyielding gatekeeper. The truth originates from a higher source. It passes into the heart where it is rigorously deliberated and weighed against divine measure, and only when it is perfectly aligned is the tongue permitted to articulate it.
The townspeople listen to the Persian elder and realize his tongue is firmly stationed behind his heart.
He embodies the exact transmissive authority he just defined.
Which completely shifts the dynamic of the room.
The scholar rises, recognized as a gateway.
He created with his power, then arranged everything perfectly. He determined a path through his generosity, then guided his creation towards it. He brought forth a path of the pasture land, then made his outer form a dried up brush and its inner aspect broad in scope and content. His knowledge does not exist outwardly so that the unworthy could possess and alter it.
Instead, his knowledge is benevolent and well protected because of its excellence. concealed, its secrets guarded for those worthy of them. Its dignity is the splendid robe of guidance, and its perfection is the garment of piety. It is marked out by the light of lights, entrusted safely in the hearts of the best and the chosen ones, the truly pious, the guardians, the protectors, the generous, and the recorders. This knowledge is a trust which they safely pass on, and they do not transgress the divine ordinances.
He honored his knowledge by hiding it and making it inward, protected it by keeping it secret, veiled it with his obligations, and crowned it with his covenants. For it cannot be reached by the aspirations of those who rely on the strength of their intellects, nor attained by those scheming for it. Its outer aspect is a reminder and a sign for the rightly guided, while its inner aspect is a sweet drink gushing forth.
His lofty heavens come down close, his earth is paved for those who inquire about him, his guiding stars are organized for those who seek him, and he has signs whose wonders follow each other in succession, pointing to him through their symbols.
I'm following you.
His accustomed way is preferment, preferring the righteous over the unrighteous. His method is approached through distinguished ranks. He cannot be accessed without his intermediaries. This is why we have the concept of the linking means in everything.
He has made his ways a guide and a path leading to good with its outer.
a protective shell, and a sign pointing toward its inner dimensions.
I have no words of my own, for I am following the words of another. For those of you listening, we know that passage is extraordinarily dense, but the weight of that sermon reshapes our entire understanding of reality.
We really must carefully break down what the scholar just laid out. This grand distinction involves the Zahir.
The outer observable physical forms we see in the material world.
Yes, and the text claims that this outer reality actively protects the batten.
The inner spirit.
Exactly. What we are looking at here is not merely a method for interpreting ancient texts. It is a cosmic preservation principle. Spiritual realities are immensely fragile and vulnerable if left exposed to the unrefined egos of humanity.
If pure divine truth were left unprotected, human ambition would possess it, alter it, and corrupt it to serve its own ends.
So the creator systematically veiled these profound realities within physical, tangible creations to immortalize them.
Think of the shell of the exterior holding spiritual realities. The physical universe, the seasons, the predictable paths of the stars, the strict laws of nature, and even physical religious rituals, it all acts as an enduring protective structure.
By encoding the truth into the outer architecture of the world, the truth endures even when the people fail. Generations will pass, entire civilizations will rise and fall, but the physical shell remains, safely carrying the inner essence across time.
It is a brilliant mechanism.
of preservation. However, there is a catch. You cannot decipher this code relying merely on your own intellect. The sermon makes it explicitly clear profound truths cannot be accessed without intermediaries. The chosen trustees, they are the Wasilla.
The linking means in everything. Without the appointed guide, you are just staring at the outer shell, completely blind to the sweet drink gushing forth inside.
We see this exact dynamic mirrored in the Quran, specifically in the chapter of the cattle, verse 59, in the translation by Pictall.
It states that with him are the keys of the unseen, known only to him, and that not a leaf falls without his knowledge, recorded in a clear record.
The observable falling leaf is the outer.
Yes, and the clear record is the inner, held securely by the divine, and it is released only through the designated trustees. Cosmic order is documentary and deliberate. This is precisely why Adam was taught all the names at the beginning of creation.
The spiritual sustenance, the custodians of this knowledge, were established first.
Right, humanity was then created in a state of ignorance, but equipped with a specific drive to seek out those pre-established fountainheads.
The intensity of this delivery completely overcomes the group. The master finishes speaking and leaves the gathering, but one person follows him back to his inn.
the youngest townsman, the disciple.
The stakes regarding this young man's background are vital to grasp here. His father is a great elder, the leader of a rival faction that has rejected the imam. This disciple comes from a direct lineage of opposition.
He was raised in an environment actively hostile to the very authority the Persian elder represents.
Yet despite that immense pressure, he approaches the master.
He addresses the scholar directly, calling him a tree with firm roots, towering splendor, and low-hanging fruit for those who desire them.
And I have to concede here. Earlier, I suspected the master was just looking for flatterers, but this young man's preface is perfect decorum, not flattery.
Because everything he recognized was truly present in the scholar's speech.
Exactly. He accurately saw the firm foundation and the accessible truth.
The gateway has been fully recognized. Having established this recognition, the young man asks the definitive question of the entire narrative. He asks, if our minds are born into ignorance and forced by need to seek,
And if the design of creation requires these specific intermediaries, what is the actual instrument by which a seeker finds life?
It is the ultimate practical question. If the truth is hidden inside the shell and the intermediaries hold the answers, what equipment do we have to connect with them?
The master answers that humanity was not left to wander in ignorance without the proper tools.
We were given a very specific instrument to navigate this shell of creation, the intellect, operating through an interconnected triad of hearing, sight, and the heart.
These are the three openings designed specifically to receive the light of knowledge.
Let us examine how numerous verses mention these three faculties together.
It is the exact same instrument every time, but its functional state depends entirely on the choices of the listener. The master walks the young man through 4 distinct phases of this instrument.
Okay, what is the first phase?
First, it is identified as a divine gift. In the chapter of the Sovereignty, verse 23, it reads, Say, it is He who has created you and endowed you with hearing, sight, and hearts.
Very few of you are grateful.
So the endowment is universal. We do not earn the capacity for truth. We all receive the instrument as baseline hardware.
Exactly. Second, this instrument is seen as sealed by refusal from the chapter of the B, verse 108. They are those upon whose hearts, hearing, and sight the divine has set a seal, and they are the heedless.
A seal means the capacity is permanently shut down.
The openings are rendered useless because the individual continually refused to process what was heard and seen.
Third, the instrument is described as covered. In the chapter of the cow, verse 7, the Creator has set a seal on their hearts and on their hearings and on their eyes there is a covering. Theirs will be a great torment.
This implies an obstruction, a self-imposed barrier to reality.
And finally, 4th, it is the mechanism of ultimate accountability. In the chapter of the Children of Israel, verse 36, indeed the hearing, the sight, and the heart of each of those, you will be questioned.
It is the exact same instrument in all four verses, but utilized in four entirely different ways based on human agency.
The critical theological takeaway here is that the error is never the absence of the instrument. The failure is entirely based on what the listener chose to do with it.
The call is heard clearly, the signs are seen vividly, and the true is recognized inwardly.
From that point, they are either accepted and acted upon, or they are ignored, covered, and ultimately sealed by pride.
We are fully equipped. The excuses we often make for our own spiritual stagnation simply do not hold up, because the mechanism for seeking is completely intact.
This connects the argument from the instrument directly to the argument from the messenger. The 2 concepts really cannot be separated.
We see this stitched together
beautifully in the chapter of Women, verse 165, again using the Pictole translation. It states that messengers are sent to bring good cheer and warning so that mankind might have no argument against the Almighty after the messengers.
A demand for obedience is not issued without first providing both the internal means to process it and the external messenger to deliver it.
There are two halves of the same cosmic case. The theological conclusion we arrive at is absolute.
The court of the hereafter is a court in which the defense of ignorance has already been retired before the trial even begins.
In A worldly court, you might successfully claim that you simply did not know the law.
But in the divine court, you cannot claim deprivation when you were handed the instrument of the intellect, and the guides were stationed in the world waiting for your inquiry over in the river country.
The young man in our narrative is standing right at the threshold. He has heard the intricate cosmic design.
He has recognized the gate. He has admitted his own deep neediness by overcoming his hostile lineage, and he has asked for the way to life.
And the master has placed the responsibility squarely back into the young man's own physical and spiritual being. The 3 openings of the human body, hearing, sight, and the heart, perfectly align with the three answering provisions of the relying order, which are the messengers, the imams, and the callers.
The disciple is equipped, and therefore he is accountable.
He is.
And as we conclude our examination of this extraordinary exchange, we are forced to prepare our listener to look at their own standing within this exact same design.
I have no words of my own, for I am following the words of another.
Of the three openings hearing, sight, and the heart, which has gone sealed this week, through what you refuse to inquire about, and what would it cost tomorrow to begin asking?